en este vídeo vamos a hablar acerca de
uno de los tipos más comunes de curvas
que van a ver en matemáticas y esa es la
parábola y la palabra para volar no
suena bastante elegante pero veremos que
está describiendo algo bastante sencillo
ahora en términos de por qué es llamada
parábola bueno he visto un montón de
explicaciones la palabra para hablar
viene del griego para qué significa algo
junto a am oa un lado o algo en paralelo
y bolt a la misma raíz que usamos cuando
hablamos por ejemplo de balística y
significa arrojando a algo así que
podría interpretarlo junto como a un
lado de él o algo que está siendo
arrojado ahora cómo se relaciona esto
con las curvas que tenemos aquí bueno mi
cerebro inmediatamente supone que esto
de aquí es una trayectoria este es el
movimiento aunque es una aproximación
muy buena para el recorrido de las cosas
que son arrojadas cuando estudian física
verán
movimiento y aproximarán el recorrido de
objetos que son arrojados como parábolas
así que tal vez de ahí es de donde viene
esta idea pero también hay otras
posibles explicaciones del por qué esto
se llama una parábola explicaciones que
se han perdido a lo largo de la historia
pero bueno en realidad que es una
parábola en vídeos futuros vamos a
describirla de una manera más precisa y
más algebraica pero en este vídeo solo
quiero que tengamos un sentido común de
cómo se ven las parábolas e
introducirnos a una terminología
alrededor de este concepto entonces
observa estas tres curvas todas son
versiones dibujadas a mano de una
parábola ahora bien si ves estas tres
puedes observar que algunas de ellas
abren hacia arriba
como esta de color anaranjado o esta de
color rosa y otras abren hacia abajo
como esta parábola de color verde y de
hecho escucharás a la gente decir cosas
como abren hacia abajo
hacia arriba y por lo tanto es bastante
bueno saber de qué están hablando así
que déjame escribirlo esta parábola de
ver de las parábolas que se parecen a
esta parábola de verde van a ser
parábolas que abren hacia abajo son como
una invertida mientras que esta parábola
de color anaranjado me voy a decir que
abre hacia arriba al igual que todas las
palabras que se parezcan a ella es decir
que tengan la forma de una v yo creo que
esto es bastante autoexplicativo las
parábolas que abren hacia abajo abren
hacia la parte inferior de la gráfica y
es por eso que esta naranja se ve como
una un mientras que esta verde se ve
como una pero invertida esta rosa
también estaría abierta hacia arriba por
ejemplo ahora otro término que verán
asociado con la parábola y una vez más
en el futuro aprenderemos a calcular los
y encontrarlos con precisión es la idea
de ver 3 en 10 bert se podrían verlo
como el punto máxi
o mínimo en una parábola así que si una
parábola abre hacia arriba como estas
dos que tenemos en la derecha el vértice
va a ser el punto mínimo el punto mínimo
que tenemos por ejemplo aquí déjame
escribirlo
este es el vértice y si alguien dice
cuál es el vértice de esta parábola de
color anaranjado bueno me parece que la
coordenada en x es de 3.5 aquí lo puedes
ver y la coordenada en james es
aproximadamente menos 3.5 y una vez más
una vez que empecemos a representar
estas parábolas con ecuaciones tendremos
técnicas para calcular con mayor
precisión todo esto que estamos viendo
ahora el vértice de esta otra parábola
con apertura hacia arriba es de nuevo el
punto mínimo el punto más bajo y es que
observa no hay un punto máximo en una
parábola con la apertura hacia arriba
solo sigue aumentando a medida de que x
es mayor en dirección positiva
negativa ahora en dado caso de que la
parábola abra hacia abajo entonces el
verde se va a ser su punto máximo y
bueno relacionado con esta idea de
vértice tenemos la idea de un eje de
simetría en general cuando estamos
hablando no sólo de dos dimensiones e
incluso en tres dimensiones pero
especialmente en dos dimensiones pueden
imaginar una recta sobre la cual se
puede girar la gráfica y encontrar
exactamente lo mismo como doblarla en sí
misma es decir un eje de simetría
entonces el eje de simetría para esta
parábola de color anaranjado va a ser
esta recta observa podrían doblarla para
hablar sobre esta recta y vas a
encontrar exactamente lo mismo bueno
aunque tal vez está afectando las dibuje
tan impecable como deberían porque bueno
esta recta debería ir directamente por
encima del vértice
pero creo que tienes una idea y si
quieres saber la ecuación esta recta
bueno pues vas a decir que x va a ser
igual a 3.5 del mismo modo si nos fija
en el eje de simetría para esta parábola
rosa entonces debería de ser esta recta
que es la recta x igual a menos 1 este
va a ser nuestro eje de simetría y el
eje de simetría para esta parábola de
verde bueno vamos a dibujar ese eje de
simetría y ok pasar por encima del
vértice y parece que es la recta x igual
a menos 6 así que vamos a escribir que
estos son nuestros ejes de simetría ejes
de simetría ahora bien otro concepto que
no es exclusivo de las parábolas pero
que hablaremos bastante de ello es la
idea de intersecciones porque
seguramente has escuchado que alguien
diga la intersección con el eje james o
la intersección con el eje x o que te
pregunten de dónde intersec a la curva
al eje y entonces observa por aquí la
intersección en kiev de esta parábola
anaranjada estaría justo aquí parece que
es el punto 0 3
y si nos fijamos en la intersección en
tiempo de la parábola rosa bueno
observan está justo por aquí y si nos
fijamos en la intersección en tiempo de
la parábola de verde bueno en este caso
no se ve pero quiero que esté seguro de
que inter se cara al eje y solamente que
está muy bueno bastante lejos de esta
pantalla ahora también podríamos estar
familiarizados con el término
intersección en x y este es un término
interesante especialmente con las
palabras y esto lo vamos a ver con más
claridad en el futuro por ejemplo en la
parábola de naranja am aquí tenemos una
intersección con el eje x en dos lugares
y es por eso que se vuelve interesante
las rectas solo intersectan al eje x una
sola vez como máximo pero aquí veremos
que la parábola puede inter secar al eje
x dos veces ya que curvan y después
inter seca de nuevo al eje x no siempre
es así pero puede pasar y aquí en este
caso las intersecciones en x van a ser
los puntos bueno tengo el punto 1
y el punto 6 0 y seguramente puedes
notar que aquí pasa algo muy interesante
ya que las intersecciones en x son
simétricas alrededor del eje de simetría
así que deberían de ser equidistantes a
ese eje y aquí puedes ver que en
realidad lo están ambos puntos están
exactamente a 2.5 de separación de ese
eje de simetría entonces por ejemplo si
saben dónde están las intersecciones
bueno solo toman el punto medio de las
coordenadas en x y luego van a tener ahí
el eje de simetría la coordenada x del
eje de simetría y además la coordenada x
del vértice real de igual manera las
intersecciones en x de esta parábola
verde parece que son los puntos observan
es el punto menos 70 y el menos 50 y la
coordenada x del vértice o la recta de
simetría está justo en medio de esos dos
puntos ahora vale la pena notar que no
todas las palabras van a interceptar al
eje x
noten por ejemplo que esta parábola de
rosa con apertura hacia arriba tiene un
punto mínimo que está sobre el eje x así
que de plano nunca va a entrar secar al
eje x real por lo tanto puede que las
palabras no intersectan al eje x
y bueno hasta aquí los voy a dejar estas
son en realidad algunas ideas
principales o temas principales
alrededor de las parábolas y las vamos a
discutir con mucho detalle y mucho
cuidado cuando las representamos con
ecuaciones y como verán a estas
ecuaciones van a involucrar términos de
segundo grado así que por ejemplo la
parábola más simple que conocemos es la
parábola y igual a x cuadrada pero
después pueden complicarlo un poco y
podrán tener cosas con bom igual a 2 x
cuadrada menos 5 x 7 este tipo de
palabras de las que vamos a estar
hablando en términos más generales se
les conoce con el nombre de 4 ticas y en
general están representadas por
parábolas